this is a production of cornell
university
well thank you for coming this afternoon
it's going to be a little different
seminar from what you're used to instead
of giving getting
receiving some data and some facts we're
going to have the students from
horticulture 4940
give their final oral presentation from
their trip to easter island this is a
special topics class that's offered this
semester
thanks to the generosity of susan lynch
who's been a very generous donor to the
college of agriculture
and
as part of this class the students spent
their spring break on easter island
which you know is part of chile
and they're going to talk to us today
about what they did
not all our class normally meets on
tuesday so
they couldn't
not all the students can come here today
hi there i'm jason thank you all for
coming
i'll be talking about santiago chile
while constructing our original interior
for the trip we didn't quite plan on
spending time in the city of santiago
however due to some unexpected issues we
ended up spending the entirety of our
first day and a portion of the second
day with big city
nevertheless we welcomed the opportunity
and ended up enjoying our time in
santiago
after checking into our hotel which was
very modernistic and comfortable we sat
down on foot to find most dominicos
which is an open-air handcraft market
that features handmade artisanal goods
here we spent a few hours pursuing the
wares and crafts which included
everything from pet parrots to ceramics
and jewelry
following the time we spent at los
dominicos we all enjoyed delicious meals
found in a restaurant specializating in
brewed inn cuisine
the following day before settling out
for easter island we hopped on a double
decker bus and received a tour of
santiago and learned about its history
with the assistant of a guide
we passed through its many districts and
saw a handful of important sites which
included the palacio de la moneda which
serves as the seat of the president
after an
informative tour of santiago we head to
the airport and we're on our way to
eastern
so
um the village of honduras was like any
other village we've ever been to
it was very small and had a few
cobblestone roads that
led on to
the small beach in town that seemed to
get the social center of their island
there were bars and restaurants that
lined the streets where there was open
air ceiling
oh is this tropical island music that
you could hear playing
we learned that
the main mode of transportation was most
they had a lot of cars and trucks but
because of the
dirt roads there they use a lot of dirt
bikes
and once in a while you pass on the
street by someone
on horseback
riding around town
we were also granted the company of a
lot of
many dogs
um
they
at first we thought they were all
straight but we quickly learned from our
tour guide that they're actually
um they're all owned they're just part
of that laid-back kind of life
um
the
town also blessed us with a palm sunday
mass with a song
or a song
which is their
traditional language
there was also a fresh produce market
and plenty of shops and superheroes for
stuff
so while we're in easter island and
santiago we got the chance to experience
various delicious foods um
so breakfast usually consists of fresh
fruit
eggs crepes
here's
the omelet that we got meat and always
fresh
fruit juice
so the meals that we usually had were
very meat heavy so it's hard to find
vegetarian meals
most meals
included freshly caught fish
and
others included local beef and chicken
the meals also included
island-grown taro and sweet potatoes but
the sweet potatoes there actually what
they call sweet potatoes are actually
yams and they
came they're very prevalent on the
island and came in both yet orange and
purple
so the meals there were tended to be a
mix between both chile and traditional
food but with more seafood and also
more westernized meals like we had pizza
one night
um
we all got to try ceviche which was the
first for me and ended up being really
delicious and dr b got to have his
favorite traditional chilean drink from
pisco sour
and so but due to the island's
remote location and the high information
costs all food prices were really really
high
but overall we all really enjoyed the
food and enjoyed what they had
all right
a little bit about what a moai and off
you are
here you'll see a picture of the moai
which are the human-like figures which
are carved of stone and they are really
known to have distinct hands and long
fingernails and they're standing on a
platform which is called an ahu the ahu
are long with wings and they have
stones in front of them these are
primarily used as a way to worship the
ancestors
some people actually actually come in
front of the ahu and sit and gather to
have different ceremonies in order to
um worship their ancestors
we visited two different offices here
you'll see this is ontatongaruki where
they actually have 15 standing moai
another one we went to was ahu tahai but
they didn't have quite as many moai but
then they were as well preserved but it
was still a very well established ahu on
the island
um also at ongota high we were able to
see this structure which was uh
the remnants of an old house which was
actually the way they had it was um just
this
round framework with a canoe was
actually placed on top of it and so it
was just a very small shelter that they
would just use because they were mainly
outdoor people because of the good
weather and but they would just have
this small shelter that they would use
to sleep in and the most their time has
been outdoors
so on our second day we visited the
volcanic crater uh rana radar which is
on the side of the quarry where most of
the moai were carved
and
we had a special opportunity here to
talk with archaeologists from ucla who
are completing um an excavation of some
of the moa which you can see right here
these statues were carved in any
position that they would kind of fit
into the rock using stone tools called
toki um
and these are made of ball salt and
subsidian rocks
um
the spine was the last they would carve
face up on their backs the spine was the
last portion
carved and cut away from the rock and
then they would be set up in a pit so
that the back of the mower could have
carved and often had interesting designs
called petroglyphs in them
around 90 moai have been excavated from
the quarry and a lot of them were
excavated in non-archaeological
conditions which has made piecing
together the history of the moai much
tougher for archaeologists today
we also
had the opportunity to see the moai
in transport
down from the quarry in places where
they had fallen or broken
and um
also been placed into the ground and
just never taken out of there and so the
soil has filled it around it had a very
eerie and
comparison piece of that here
was another quarter we got to visit on
our itinerary
it's the quarry where the top mounts
were made top-notch are
these um
they're almost like half they're round
uh
carved out of red storia it's a
different rock than the moai were carved
out of
only certain loba i got to wear these
and it showed that they were at a higher
power taking on the chief
um
there are several theories about how the
top knots were placed on top of the foam
line one of the theories is whether or
not the moai were laying down and they
kind of like tied up with rope on their
heads and then they erected it straight
up um but these are all theories and we
don't really know exactly
so
during our time at uh in charlotte we
got to hide to one of those several
volcanoes the three major ones one of
them being twitty
it took us roughly 30 minutes to reach
the top of the highest point there
and once there we were amazed by how
isolated we published in the distance
and they're basically a thousand miles
of uninterrupted to largely
uninterrupted sea just anywhere you can
see
and so we then followed romo and our
guide to the other side of the hills
where there were the sites of very early
moai statues
it's been determined that these statues
were left at the smallest and then they
got larger as time went on they had
carving larger and larger statues and so
these in the line were likely carved
between the states of 9118
after this site we continued on to a
cave made by a lava tube known as the
cave of the virgins where the women were
once kept to pale their skin because
paleness was a sign of beauty in that
culture so they were kept there for
months and so we got to crawl in there
five at a time and see the petroglyphs
on the side of the wall
okay so i'm gonna talk about random cow
um it's one of the larger volcanic
craters on the island it's about 200 000
years old and a mild diameter and to
this day it's probably one of the most
incredible things i've ever seen
um not only is it aesthetically really
pretty but it is also like an enormous
source of um
sustaining the population of easter
island with its like vast array of
plants
uh in life within the crater um we
learned about ramona regarding us a lot
about like the biodiversity
that is in the crater there's medicinal
burn that lies with the computer that is
using cancer
there's also been analysis of the mud
water composition that has been
determined to stuff the growth of dna
increasing the longer video on life
which i mean you can kind of say that
and set up committee like that
and as well as recently there have been
um plans have served as their original
medicine address
which as ramona told us the rapid new
year people get vip access to them
so cool hero is the fertility zone that
the ancient refugee people would play to
promote
fertility among its people the noise
made by the fertility zone resembles a
common shell
fertility petroglyphs are carved into
stone all over its surface
showing the significance of fertility in
their culture ramon taught us how to
play the stone which can be quite the
task you can either
cuff one end the other side of that hole
and hit it to make the sound or you can
blow into it so a few of us gave it a
try and only joy is here was successful
um
there are also bugs calling in another
bit which also made it a little
difficult
so our next stop this day was to enable
the world
and this is a stone that is said to have
been carried to the island by its first
king hotu matua
having to travel thousands of miles
across the pacific where this large
stone proved its meaning to the rocky
people it is said to possess heavy doses
of mana the spiritual power bestowed by
the gods
from facing one's hands on the stone
mana will bring them health and energy
we all got the chance to touch the stone
before leaving the site in hopes that we
would absorb some of this energy
so i'm going to talk about boating
struggling and tell you guys a little
bit about the vermeer cult um so on our
first date i like revisited random cat
which i talked about before and abrondo
and um
back um in history historically aroma
used to be the center of the village
and um
during the birmingham era which is when
basically you had rivaling tribes or
plans and they each year
they put a competition where like young
boys would um compete to lead for the
following year so they would swim out to
the islands which were shown um in the
picture of montenegro
and they would swim out there and the
person who collects an egg and gets back
up the mountain um first is the one who
will basically go back here and um
basically group the academy intact and
um you have to um
they also spent some time out on the
islands as they got there um meditating
and kind of getting touched spiritually
with um
so that was interesting we learned about
that from up there and then
later in the week we had a chance to go
out and on a boat ride and um see like
the islands up close and which was
really cool the water was beautiful it
was
like the brightest blue indigo you've
ever seen it was really pretty and um it
was just amazing to see that like you
want to swim out there and actually come
back and skip oh you don't see it here
but you can probably see that make sure
that the
that one side is pretty steep so it's
been pretty difficult to scale like
trying to keep an eye on your hat and a
lot of times our tour guide promotes
that that people put in there like could
put in their mouths
so and then it was like a really rainy
day when we did this and um for most of
the simple there's lots of opportunities
and it was interesting to see because
there weren't a lot of fish or anything
and it was really like not your typical
snorkeling experience because it wasn't
like that much like coral life or um
anything like in the sea very much like
you saw probably free fish but it was
awesome
nonetheless um and on the way back we
saw about like
multiple rainbows framing the
science that were really pretty
much about time we spent
learning about local flora at the
botanical garden column kind of is
extremely active in
conservation of biodiversity and
involving the local community in their
efforts
they grow
a lot of our academic and
medicinal plants in their nursery and
distribution to a local to the locals
and last year they gave out thirty
thousand plans to the proper new people
oh also companies are currently involved
in attempting to reintroduce and plan on
more
engaging or endangered plants back to
easter island
for example they're
trees which are endemic to each island
and almost when
almost everything at some point
they also have a
the traditional proper new agricultural
methods like the
metal wine which are stone structures
built around the plants to protect them
from livestock and wind or strong water
and creating a microclimate to provide
the optimum moisture and temperature
so we got to visit the hospital on rough
week
because easter island has a long
tradition of using herbal medicines many
islanders have wanted them to be used in
the hospital so as a compromise there's
a special room attached to the hospital
with a separate entrance
and this allows patients to have a
choice of choosing
traditional or occidental medicine
and we were able to tour the facilities
and talk with pamela
the president of the board of wrestling
traditional medicine
and she told us that herbal treatments
are the only
one aspect of their holistic approach to
healing which treats the entire mind and
body of the patient
pamela works with three other islanders
in addition to visiting physicians and
anthropology students
in order to stretch the very limited
budget of the traditional medicine
program kayla is now using a radio show
to help the rap many people learn how to
grow and use medicinal plants at home as
well as hospitals
so the artisan market was one of the
last steps of me uh
towards the end of our trip we went to
the artisan market down the road from
our hotel essentially it's kind of a
gift shop of our experience so we were
able to grab a couple souvenirs there
and uh there was a plenty of handcrafted
handcrafted souvenirs and uh turtleness
stone and wood and it's just really
awesome in traditional
crafts and one of our classmates liz was
able to
purchase a handcrafted wood structure
that she actually saw the woman doing at
the site so that was
kind of cool and she was really upset
so after one of our last dinners
together on the island we headed to
karikari a local performance held in the
town that draws in both native and
foreign people
so when the instrumental section of this
act came out there were a lot of
drummers and guitarists and auxiliary
percussionists
we were immediately impressed with their
talent energy express through the music
next the dancers and singers filled the
stage of their traditional song and
dance
here
now i can't think of the most exciting
part of the night as a part of the
karikari show
several of us including myself got the
exhilarating opportunity to express
ourselves revenue style
one was for me quite
um she fit right in with the vibrant and
awful culture here so after seeing the
karikari ballet um
it seemed very apparent that they
probably perform this in order to keep
the traditional rap and unique culture
alive through its younger people
and it seems as though it serves as an
educational tool by exposing spectators
to their
cultural right so anaconda beach is the
beach on easter island
um it is said to be the landing place of
polynesian chief
and and settlers so these settlers
created the first settlements on rapidly
um we going up to the beach uh ramon
told us of a tsunami that hit the island
previously and wiped out 95 of the sand
so what we saw there was what was left
and it still looked like a gorgeous
beach that you'd want to be at um it's
currently home to two ahus as you
learned earlier
one of which is currently under
construction
and other homes six moai statues
now this was a particularly
significant day for myself
because it was my first time stepping
foot into an ocean
market problems we don't get out much
great experience the water was a deep
deep blue very salty
we were all loving life dr v was
floating off into the distance
um on our last day we got the
opportunity to check to the top of manga
taravaca via horseback
um magoterovaca is the highest point on
easter island at 507 meters
um
we
so we this was our only opportunity to
get to the top so we're very excited
um the views were incredible the entire
way up as you can see and when we got to
the top we all jumped off our horses and
left them at a watering hole to graze
and we all watched
it wasn't very far but the very top
and um so when we were at the top we got
to take even more incredible pictures
and we could see the curvature of the
earth on the horizon because you can see
so much of the ocean around you which
was really incredible
on our way back down we got to
see even more great views of hangaroa
and the ocean
around us
and
the weather held out perfectly it was a
beautiful sunny day we all got plenty
sunburned
and
but just right as we were getting back
to the ranch it started to drizzle a
little which actually was welcome after
the hot day in the sun
um so this was actually the high point
of my trip and i think everyone agrees
that it was a well worthwhile threat
so uh
on richard childers i was the defective
translator for the trip being almost
fluent in spanish and so when we're here
in the states we never really worry
about whether or not the guy in
starbucks is going to be able to
understand our latte order as i simply
given we'll be able to communicate to
express ourselves and what we want
because the fluent spanish speaker took
the lazy route and only really traveled
abroad in south america but it's
sometimes difficult for me to understand
this concept of not being able to
express myself
so i had the pleasure to put my
authority to good use during our trip
and although there were times i forgot
what language i was speaking and to whom
it's a flurry of questions i never had
to deal with the concept of not being
able to get my point across
of just not being able to pull the
waiter aside and ask if this strange
sauce i've never seen before has
shellfish or if the empanadas are vegan
or not
so although i tried to find answers for
as many questions as i could especially
in the little times which were kind of
crazy
uh i know it must have been a hassle for
you to deal with
and so i also know there's a fair bit of
culture that one misses out on in such
cases there were times when locals would
crack little jokes or tell stories might
be the only one chuckling
creeper in the corner
and believe me if uh retelling a joke
less than the humor translating it makes
it ten times worse
and this was no exception
i want to thank all of you who left
anyhow
sorry i couldn't make it more
understandable
so i guess in general i'd like to
recognize my fellow group members
both for their patience and flexibility
and for their dedication to going and
learning and having fun no matter what
the language barriers and i hope that
through my translation i kind of ease
some of these difficulties
so now we'll begin the part of the
presentation where we talk about the
many research projects that different
groups of students on the trip
developed and participated in throughout
the trip
the project group that i was in charge
of was a
sort of plant identification scavenger
hunt in which we
looked at the biodiversity on ireland by
comparing what species we thought would
be there from
looking at
finding species names in books and on
the internet that were connected with
easter island and before the trip we
were able to find 131 species names
specifically associated with mr island
but finding a total species number was
quite challenging and we came up with
212 from a few different sources online
and
this was a number that was challenging
to find because often um
the number 47 would be mentioned as the
number of native higher plant species
going out which is kind of ambiguous
um this fairly small species count you
notice the idea that the biodiversity in
the island would be very low and that it
would be fairly thin and desolate
however upon arriving we discovered that
this was not in fact the case
much of the island is covered in rolling
grass vistas and you wouldn't know it
from a large variety of trees mango
avocado palm china berry eucalyptus
beautiful cultivated tropical flowers
and plants general lush vegetation
of the island's only town angora
we were lucky enough to visit our tour
guide's house for lunch and explore his
extensive and frankly overwhelming
gardens which contain many classic
tropical plants that are found across
the globe which we hadn't included
previously on our list
overall we photographed 101 more species
than the original 131 and we're also
able to find and photograph many of
those as well
the two methods for attaining our
species counts were combined allowing us
to account for 232 species on the island
20 more than the number of 212 that were
previously documented
so after the trip we all everyone in our
group
was reflected on the plant biodiversity
on the island we came up with some
interesting conclusions
um
the species count is low especially even
in comparison to our local infra new
york
in many ways this actually provided a
greater experience of the concept of
biodiversity because we were able to
understand the vastness and subtlety of
difference within the kingdom plantae on
a comprehensible scale
even if only 232 species
we learned about and experienced first
first-hand harmful medicinal delicious
and fascinating plants found all across
the island we saw grasses that made
horses ill plants that treat cancer and
enjoyed fresh mangoes off of a tree just
steps away from our hotel on a daily
basis
the prevalence of food crops was
especially notable in terms of
people's ability to create their own
sustainable paradigms
the biodiversity was also emphasized by
the hotspot that
alexa mentioned grano cow in which
almost all the plants on the island grow
and some plants that are found nowhere
else on the island grow
so like most people haven't considered
this term the oed to find biodiversity
is the diversity of plant animal life
especially as represented by the number
of texan species we discovered that this
term is both nuanced and complicated and
carries numerous implications and it's
important to consider in the context of
specific places
simply counting species numbers skews
one's perspective of a place and of
their perception of ecosystems
sustainability and value
and so it also is a fatalistic
perspective for a place like easter
island and failed to consider that the
people like the ravanui can restore the
biodiversity of their environment by
attempting to document biodiversity of
the stereotypical way we ended up
discovering that this concept is much
harder to nail down than wants to be
thought and it means more than just a
number
and these are some pictures of plants
that can be found both native and
a little bit more typical
okay so hi i'm alexa
i me and maddie kind of took
charge of this we came up with the idea
of transects and megan um helped us out
with um
transects in the island um
and we kind of did something similar to
eliza's group but we kind of tried to
make it a little bit more
um but we decided to do the objective of
our play divider csa was to assess the
composition of advanced species
throughout eastern island
based on our data and um so given the
history of the deforestation oyster
island and the
depletion of the native platfora it was
a big question in our minds as to like
okay what the species are there and like
where what is their spread like on the
island so our goal is to obtain a
quantitative analysis of the species
diversity at various locations on the
island by calculating like a percentage
of abundance of
each species in each study that we
visited
um so prior to departure our group and
liz's group can work together to compile
a plan species id booklet um
off the internet and like getting
pictures on the internet that we can
identify what we found and while on the
island we um took transects at each um
spot
as many spots as we could that we
visited and our train set was eight
meters in length and we did 400 watts
four meter you know four one meter
clocks thoughts
to transact and photograph these species
that we found on the transect and
surrounding it as well
and
it identified it using the previous iv
build
we took data at
random rare to the highest point of
mafia terribaca which is photographed
hoiki peninsula
konam
um
so the the poster in the hallway shows a
figure with the species compositions
that we found and we found that there
was a range of abundances and varieties
of different species at each site
each all sites though had a large number
of varying species of grass and
speculation says that this grassland
landscape has existed on the island
since the natives over harvested the
trees for timber and overused slash and
burn on agriculture techniques to feed
the overpopulation
in the 15th century the peak of this
populance was recorded between 7 000 and
10 000 inhabitants
on the island
but it's
controversial however whether or not
this directly related in the
deforestation
regardless deforestation
did lead to dwindling and
extinction of various
original native species
an example of this being the native palm
tree which was harvested for lumber and
all the nuts were eaten by both humans
and rats that were brought to the island
as a result it was eliminated as a
species
our when comparing the results of the
various sites
on you can see the difference in native
versus invasive between konaf and the
other sites quite obviously
this is due to conex restoration
project for the native plants of easter
island so within their borders they
contained much less invasive species
but outside of their control was quite
the opposite so the establishment of
invasive species especially facilitated
in the areas where there is no
restoration of projects
in the future increased number and size
of transects on in more locations would
probably be needed to get an accurate
biodiversity assay of the island
an investigation into why each site um
where it's composed of different species
would also be really interesting and
could be done by
a more
comprehensive composite plant
composition species throughout the
island and studies of the various
microclimates and histories and
topography of the land
so i will be presenting massive bonds
research objectives and findings
you can be here for the presentation but
he will be here after
i don't know 15-20 minutes if anybody
has questions for him
so the goal of messi's research project
was to conduct a survey of the plants
using revenue in medicine approximately
80 of the world's population relies
primarily on natural health products as
sources of medicine
this occurs even in areas where western
biomedicine is available due to easier
access cultural preference and lower
cost easter island is an ideal location
to survey medicinal plants because the
use of herbal medicines is a strong part
of their culture
this island hospital or the island
hospital even includes an attached
clinic where traditional medicines are
administered like discussed before
because very few books and articles have
been written about the ref revenue and
ethnobotany most information was made by
interviewing four of the islanders who
are showing us archaeological sites
ramon our tour guide also
helped us out with this
he grew up on the island and used many
medicinal plants regularly regularly
such as a mixture of ginger root and
sugar cane which was taken for coughs
and stomach cramps
while ramon drove us around the island
he also pointed out plants like castor
bean soaring along the road which can be
used to ease joint pain and inflammation
one of her mom's friends had even spent
several years being treated at the
hospital with very little effect and
after being switched using castor bean
instead of
contemporary medicine her condition
rapid rapidly improved so that's an
interesting story
another important source of
ethnobotanical information was george
the growing manager of pronoun
he described several important medicinal
species one of these is how naco naco
a plant in the nightshade family which
produces a small tomato-like berry this
fruit is very nutritious and is eaten to
treat rashes and stomach illness
one of the most interesting plants we
saw was matua hua a fern that has shown
high potential in tests as an
anti-cancer drug
the islanders drink a tea made from its
roots to treat fractures sprains
menstrual cramps burns and bruises
the person we met with the most
knowledge of verbal medicine was pamela
puck
from the traditional side of the
hospital
she grows dozens of plants at her house
on conapt property in other locations on
the island used for treating for
patients
this project identified a total of 23
medicinal plants representing 20
different families
however this is most likely only a
fraction of all of the plants used on
easter island
because of the use of herbal treatments
on the island is still alive and well
both at the hospital and in daily living
easter island provided
an ideal location to study not only the
patients but the context of how they are
integrated into rapid
culture all right so many of us being
from horse backgrounds thought it would
be interesting to
study horses and diversity effects on
the island so elizabeth jay and myself
headed up this research group
um we learned that earlier in the
history on easter island
horses were consumed as a source of food
but now that biodiversity
is
on its way upward and resources are more
readily available the horse meat is no
longer needed
but because of the overpopulation of
horses
uh many of the natives would like to see
the consumption of horses promoted once
again particularly population
currently on the island there are 5 000
horses
and 5 800 people so it's just about a
one to one ratio
when talking to the researchers at konap
they said that ideally they'd like to
see two to four hectares per horse
on the island
and the island is 160 hectares
square kilometers
so
when doing the map you would need 100 to
200 square kilometers of land so they
are dealing with space issues
when talking to konap
their goal is to reintroduce the
speed like native species
and various other plants to the island
and they're facing many issues with
horses as far as keeping those plants
alive so they're often building barriers
around the plants shrunkery
what not to keep the horses out
and if you go back to the previous
picture they're trying to keep the
horses away from the moai statues the
more the horses are using the ahus and
the scratching posts so they're actually
eroding away the statues
so they put in these turnstiles that
ideally only humans are
physically capable
but
there are horses on the other side and
they are grazing directly in front of
the eyes
and using them as rather close to it
they're doing what they can to keep them
out jason can you go back are
those gopher holes
or something else these here yes those
are rocks those are wrong
oh and also um
horses
they're all owned the five thousand
horses on the island are all owned by
someone but they're roaming free and
they must they mostly take care of
themselves so you all you'll always see
a brand on them
so you can find their owner
and
often courses are seen as a status
symbol on the island more horses you
have
higher you are
so some natives would like to see a role
play an effect that limits the person to
how many horses they can own
and often you'll see
islanders
utilizing those transportation so i
think they'll see
so much now as you did in the past
all right
so
my my group for our research for young
fun
kaitlyn and i was to investigate food
crops on easter island
we
sorry i'm really nervous
so okay so our group was to investigate
the food crops on the island and we
also were interested in the climate and
irrigation systems
um the methods we use to collect our
data was through uh resources through
using
uh through observing at restaurants and
menus and seeing what ingredients were
often on menus
through
observations at farms that we have
visited and family family farms and
gardens and also at the local food
markets
you can see what was imported and what
was
locally grown
so
the results that we found because it was
definitely a consistent group of crops
that were consumed and also highly grown
on the island um such include tarot
sweet potato banana mango and guava
guava sorry and
we found those as consistent staples in
our meals and also
we saw them growing in the fields
obviously
the museum
museum day anthropological sebastian and
endler which is a museum on easter
island uh
recognized sporting crops as the most
important crops on easter island some of
which are food crops and some of which
are ethnomechanically important and
important
some of our meals most of our meals
consisted of
for breakfast guava and mango and
bananas my
maddie had shown earlier
and for lunch we
had
mostly sandwiches and our ingredients
were mostly tomato and cheese and
my speculation is that the cheese is
imported we didn't see cattle per se or
not at least
enough to
produce
and for dinner uh those foods we had a
side of dish with a side of sweet potato
for uh master chips and they had a
variety of seafood on the island um
and um
so
an observation that i just wanted to
point out is that the size of the fruit
was
uh
obviously different for me at least um
for example the pineapples
were about like seven to eight inches
tall whereas my mom can sometimes like
pineapples are like huge and then uh but
in contrast the watermelon was
relatively large compared to the
watermelon in the united states so
i thought that was another subject
matter to be investigated in the future
for
in terms of the marketplace where we
also collected some of our data
pictures we found various other crops
such as uh cabbage uh basil cilantro
chives pumpkin cucumber garlic
some of which are imported in
southwestern
island
another major
source for us for our information with
ramon our tour guide which we had
discussed previously a lot has been a
really great help to us in their project
and he uh gives a tour of his garden at
home where he grows
pretty much all of the crops that i've
mentioned previously and
um
every nine months and how he cuts back
to shoot after it fruits and new babies
emerged from the ground and it's kind of
a continuous process
which was really great and some
practices that are unique to star island
is
um
with their incorporation of their
culture and agriculture practices is
planting new uh cuttings plant cuttings
during the new moon and planting
seeds during full moon
also
there is a prevalence of male farmers
because women are
traditionally not supposed to be farming
when they're on the administration cycle
so there's mostly male farmers for that
purpose
and um
another traditional practice for
agriculture is to have the quantified
which were the stone structures
surrounding the trees
which young front had discussed which
are used to
pretty much promote the optimum
temperature moisture on the plant within
the structure by
preventing livestock from
grazing on it and
from environmental factors such as water
and
so
the reason you might need to hold
moisture in these plants like the amount
of eye were used is because easter is a
very hot tropical climate
their
hottest seasons their hottest season is
typically what our winter would be as
their dry season where they can see
anywhere between two or four inches per
month which really isn't that much water
if you're 85 plus degrees
and not dropping below 60 at night
and the soil there is also very dark
it's a weather basalt soil that's
high in ph finely textured porous
so having this dark rich and iron soil
gets really hot really quickly it
doesn't hold in the moisture
over water it
so
in the picture with the drip irrigation
it kind of makes sense that they would
have that just because you can see how
dark the slime was there
so you can see posters from all of these
presentations out in the hall and talk
to students
who are involved in them afterwards if
you have more questions
so in conclusion i just wanted to talk
about
just throughout my time at cornell the
importance of hands-on interact
interactions for sparking curiosity and
promoting excitement has been reiterated
again and again
this class followed above and beyond
that trend there's only so much
literature research writing papers and
attempting to memorize information that
you can do to try to learn about
something
the real learning in education
begins when you take this academic based
inquiry and connect it to a place
through experience
when visiting a place for an academic
trip there's a tendency to avoid certain
activities because they aren't
educational or too touristy which can
actually limit the experience's
educational potential
by reflecting back on the trip i can
think of many new experiences traveling
with a large group
being rely on one person to communicate
with a lot of the people for a week
and going out on a boat on the open
ocean and riding on a horse for the
first time for me
um that really enhanced and clarified
many things that i've learned about in
school just throughout my life um now i
have better communication teamwork
skills and patience desire to learn my
spanish a lot better
um wonder why the ocean is so clear and
what kind of organisms were on those
rocks 15 meters below us when we were
struggling
and understand in a way that only riding
can show you what it was like to travel
around before there were cars
this knowledge of place and activity
combined with vigorous minds and ability
to reflect on the contemplate are
experiences were traits that i saw
exemplified and taken advantage of by
everyone in this group
and
this provided an outstanding opportunity
for learning and experience that i and
everyone who went i'm glad
before we take some questions i forgot
to introduce the co-instructor in the
class dr betsy lam
so since i you know i work on long
island i have to participate in this
class long distance by video cam but
betsy's here every week in the class and
so she does she does majority of the
work so thank you for your help with
this she joined us
do you have any questions for the
students
yes
do you see any
reptiles or amphibians
on the island are there anything there
was there was lizards in that room
specifically but yeah the general
wizards but nothing really large
i was surprised on many of our hikes not
to see snakes i feel like that's
something about home i expect to see
kind of hiking and that wasn't really
anything that you can process
yes
in his book collapse
which i recommend to all of you
jared diamond
positive the question
with regards to the fact the island was
totally deforested
what did the person think and cut down
the last
everyone was very sustainable on the
island to release their own
food
so i think at least there has been
bananas
they were gradually
eliminated by rats
going on is the island that's present
greatly they're trying to bring in
actually right now is digital and palm
and
conak believes that it's the most
similar relative to the palms which are
originally on the island and so they
think that because of the similar
climate and and
the similarities in the two palms that i
think that it'll be the most fun
uh
state line on the island so there's a
great effort from kona right now to do
that
you showed lots of examples of gardening
and producing their own food do you
think they had to import a lot of
produce as well or do you think they
basically produced kind of all of the
islands
i feel like i think from like the sense
that we bought it's like more they can
produce for themselves but like the
reason why you know prices were so high
for the classes it's hard to sustain
them all are generally in their own
population and especially now that they
become such a tourist population
but they have i mean such a large amount
of people that are coming into the
island just for touristic and like i
don't think that the small a lot of the
small personal farms like our forgotten
role he had he had like a tree of like
each species kind of but i think that
wouldn't be something that he could
really
have enough to profit and sell to the
market
yeah ramon really
we talked a lot about how like personal
sustainable they could be like a family
could sustain like was really good at
learning and knowing how to take care of
themselves and produce what they needed
to eat and to survive
in order to
provide for other people
just to add the farms we visited now you
generally see one greenhouse structure
and maybe a
one to two acre lot of ireland with
vegetables
small scale
and also i mean the great part of that
is that like the iron in general three
fourths of it i believe is protected by
kona
and then they have the small town
hungarian so it only leaves a really
small area of the island which is even
allowed
real simple question how how big is the
what are the what are the distances 168
square kilometers so seven seven miles
by fourteen miles about i mean depending
on where you take the dimensions from
the kind of triangle
it's
half the size of grand island
i have denying assumptions
that
the way that the statues got the
glorious to wherever they ended up
was well
kind of unknown
did the people that you talked to live
on the island do they have are you
there was um a few different things that
had like a couple different theories
that kind of evolved from different uh
archaeologists that have been on the
island of time actually the
archaeologist jonathan hilberg we talked
to from ucla was there at the time they
all have different theories uh
there's some that are currently go from
like they're rolling them on blogs that
the logs will roll them there's
different theories where
they'll walk them
yeah i mean there's a lot of different
theories and so it really depends on who
you talk to because um
they haven't really just like assessed
one as being correct they just can't
come up with the reasons there was a
there was a study not too long ago where
they they tried the theory of
placing them as good and then having the
logs roll the skid keep placing the
locks in front of the skid and they got
very effective results they got hundreds
of feet
throughout the time
there was a tv program which showed
but the interesting thing of course is
that it's not flat you're taking them
from the volcanic quarry down and then
to the coastline and with the nickel
theories like that and we're standing on
this large pill they call a quarry and
we're saying you want us to take this
moai here all the way over there and
you're gonna walk it
it just was so unfathomable to us at
that point that like personally i think
a lot of the other methods seemed more
reasonable but there's definitely
a lot of
support for those theories the largest
they were able to transfer was 30 feet
high i forget the 15 six times
86 times
what they're able to transport the the
build the largest ever carved with 60
feet high but it still remains in the
mountainside
in terms of um
the in terms of the oral tradition
though there is support for the theory
that the moab walked because that is
that is part of their oral tradition is
the idea that they say like the moai
walk and so they they don't know how but
part of their oral tradition is that
that is and i did read one study which
actually looked at a lot of the
transport roads and all of them had at
least a slight downhill grade to the
location of their eyes so as impossible
as it seemed to us it could that that is
a
of course it's a bit more romanticized
than flipping them on their stomachs
my favorite was the one that said they
shot them on the volcanoes
or the aliens
were they dependent on those palm trees
for food
well they used the pantries to like do
the cut canoes out of them
to get there yeah
um
any other questions
well thank you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu